[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to with the finale of Game of
Thrones right around the corner many are
waiting in anticipation to see what
could happen in the show's last few
episodes however the climactic ending
may have already been revealed on reddit
by a riposte that has since been deleted
via not though we've got all the
information you need in regards to what
happens and throughout this video I'll
be breaking down everything that you
need to know about the ending this is
full spoilers ahead so if you don't want
to have the finale of the show room for
yourself then I highly suggest that you
turn off now we won't know if this is
the case until we see the show for
ourselves so take everything with a
grain of salt but if you checked out my
Avengers and game breakdown then you'll
know that these leaks tend to be pretty
accurate so this is your last last last
chance to stop the video without the way
huge thank you for clicking on this
video I hope you enjoy it
now sit back relax and let's get into my
breakdown of the Game of Thrones Season
8 spoilers okay so the post comes from
mr. freeze knight king who was banned
from reddit after posting the leaks due
to multiple reports validating the
claims made by the user Frieza Knight
King did correctly leak beerus turning
on dani through deciding that john would
be a better leader and they did rightly
state that missandei would lose her head
at the hands of Cersei and the mountain
which of course came true they stated in
episode 5 that re-aired the Hound in
Jaime Lannister infiltrate King's
Landing through a sewer system but Jaime
is caught and imprisoned in the red keep
at Dragonstone that Daenerys his
paranoia heats the boiling point when
she realizes that Varys and Tyrion plan
on the train here she puts them both on
trial which leads to the latter being
spared but the former Varys getting
burned alive it's at this point that
Dany discovers that it was Sansa that
out her and Jon's relationship with each
other as well as Jon's true identity
which sets up a conflict between the two
per episode six the show then jumps to
the Battle of King's Landing with
Greyjoy's fleet joining the fight and
with Danny riding her last dragon drogon
the two are able to surprise and kill
urine this causes the golden
company to break their contract and from
this they all stand down and surrender
Cersei panics you to this and frees
Jaime and along with him and the
mountain she retreats to her chambers
John grey worm and Davos rushed the
landing but Cersei is actually stabbed
by Jaime in the stomach this mirrors the
death of Tulisa stark at the red wedding
but then a big twist comes with Jaime
pulling back his face to reveal a he's
actually area this ties in with what the
red woman said with her stating that
area will close many eyes including
green ones which of course says he has
the Hound bursts in at this point and
kills the mountain and everything seems
like it's over
however Daenerys wracked with paranoia
has slowly become the Mad Queen and with
her dragon she burns hundreds of
civilians soldiers and the red keep Arya
is wounded during this but the Hound
overcomes his fear of fire to save her
during this the real Jaime crawls over
to Cersei and the two die together side
by side
the final episode involves the survivors
of the battle
realizing that Dany isn't fit to lead
and taking her down in the finale Dany
accuses bran Sam and Sansa of treason
which forces Jon to reveal he is the
real heir John kills Daenerys but he
decides to relinquish the throne to bran
now people who've read this seem pretty
mad at the final twist so I don't know
if it will be the case because in my
opinion it's so bad that there's no way
this could be real I guess we will see
though but that doesn't end the show and
the finale actually closes on John going
back to the wall which is being rebuilt
due to Browns magic John searches for
tormund and finds dismembered wildling
bodies arranged in the White Walkers
spiral which showcases that they've not
been defeated and will be back and
that's all of the spoilers that we have
in regards to season 8 whether it comes
true or not we'll see but it is quite
interesting and definitely fits in with
the tone of the show and how it's going
so far
obviously I loved hear your thoughts on
these leaks and if you think that they
will happen there's quite a lot of
people angry with how the show has been
going for the final season so of course
I'd love to see what other people think
of it comment below and let me know and
if you enjoy this video then please like
it and make sure you check out my full
breakdown of every episode in the season
so far
including all of my fan theories which
will be linked in a playlist at the end
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]